- Un bar aux airs de musée
du PSG. Pour les partisans
du Paris Saint Germain,
le lieu est idéal pour regarder
des parties quand l'équipe
performe à l'étranger.
Ce soir, pour ce match
en Italie, peu de pression.
Le club est déjà qualifié
pour participer aux huitièmes
de finales de la Ligue
des champions.
Messi, Neymar, Mbappé :
il faut dire qu'au grand
désarroi des équipes rivales,
certains des meilleurs
joueurs au monde sont
dans les rangs PSG.
- Il y a des joueurs... ja
dans mon enfance, j'aurais pu
rêver ou penser que des joueurs
comme ça viennent dans le club.
- Des talents que
les propriétaires du Paris
Saint-Germain ont amplement
les moyens de s'offrir.
En 2011, un fonds
d'investissement du Qatar
est devenu l'actionnaire
majoritaire de la franchise.
Une acquisition de 70 millions
d'euros qui aurait notamment
été encouragée par le président
de l'époque, Nicolas Sarkozy.
KÉVIN VEYSSIÈRE, auteur,
"Football Club Geopolitics"
- Cpepepepermis, en tout cas por
le PSG, d'avoir une force
économique incommensurable
comparé à ses principaux
rivaux et aussi deininininstallt
sur la scène européenne en
ayant de forts investissements.
- Kévin Veyssière est auteur
de livres sur la géopolitique
du sport. Il explique que
le Qatar, hôte de la Coupe
du monde, a choisi, il y a
plusieurs années, d'utiliser
le soccer comme outil
de diplomatie.
- Ça, c'est en tout cas faire
exister le Qatar au niveau
international. En tout cas,
ça participe à cette stratégie,
le club du Paris Saint-Germain,
de faire exister le Qatar,
de l'associer à une ville
mondialement connue
qui est Paris.
- Trois ans plus tôt,
les Émirats arabes unis avaient
déjà acheté Manc C C C City
au Royaume-Uni.
D'autres pays du Golfe ont
donc adopté cette stratégie,
mais le Qatar s'est
particulièrement démarqué.
PASCAL BON I I I Inst. de rel.
internationales et stratégiques
- C'est un tout petit pays
coincé entre deux géants,
l'Arabie saoudite et l'Iran.
Et comme le Qatar se sent
cécécécé, il faut qu'il existe
et ils se sont dit :
"En achetant Neymar, Messi,
Mbappé, on sera très connus."
Alors, on a aussi acheté des
Rafale, des  d d d de chasse
à la France. Mais finalement,
peut-être que les footballeurs
sont une meilleure protection
pour le pays que les avions
de c
(cri des supporters)
(slogan)
- Il n'y a pas que le Paris
Saint-Germain qui a intéressé
des investisseurs du Qatar.
Cette équipe de la petite
ville d' d d d dans l'est de
la Belgique, a été rachetée par
une fondation du pays du Golfe
il y a maintenant 10 ans.
sisisision est bien différente
de celle du grand club
parisien de socceur.
En 2012, l'équipe de la petite
ville d'Eupen, 20 000 habitants,
était au bord de la faillite.
MICHAEL RADERMACHER,
gérant de l'équipe KAS Eupen
- Quand ils ont repris le club,
le club était mort, on était
morts et on est très contents
quand Aspire est venu
reprendre le club pour
nous donner l'opportunité
de... de rester...
rester compétitifs.
- La fondation sportive
Qatari Aspire a vu
dans ce rachat l'occasion
de s'enraciner en Europe.
- C'est parce qu'en Belgique,
c'est facile. Déjà, on peut
reprendre un club à 100 %.
Et en plus, en Belgique,
il y a moyen de laisser
jouer beaucoup des étrangers.
- Pendant plusieurs années,
l'équipe belge a recruté
de jeunes joueurs européens,
mais aussi des sportifs
venant du monde entier,
parfois des Qataris, futurs
joueurs de l'équipe nationale
du pays, mais aussi des jeunes
recrues africaines que
la fondation Aspire
voulait voir grandir
sur les terrains européens.
- Ça peut apparaître pour
le clientélisme et le fait de
donner des équipements sportifs
ou de prendre des jeunes
en stage pour les former,
les renvoyer, ça crée des liens
effectivement et, à travers
le sport, vous développez
des liens économiques et
le sport, c'est très populaire.
S'il y a un joueur quintntntnt
une vedette après avoir été
formé au Qatar, cela va avoir
un effet positif pour l'image
du Qatar dans ce pays.- - - - Cr
dans l'univers du soccer ont
culminé avec l'obtention de
la Coupe du monde cette année.
Une immense compétition qui a
attiré l'attention sur l'impact
environnemental des stades
climatisés et les conditions
des ouvriers qui les ont
construit. Plusiililililliers
de travailleurs étrangers
seraient morts au Qatar
ces dernières années,
selon une tetetete du journal
britannique "The Guardian".
- Je pense que le Qatar
a voulu miser sur la visibilité
du sport, mais qu'ils n'ont
peut-être pas calculé au départ
que cette visibilité allait
aussi s'exercer sur les aspects
les plus critiquables.
- En France, l'ambiance sera
bien différente des dernières
coupes du monde dans plusieurs
villes : pas d'espaces
dédiés aux partisans
ni d'écrans géants pour
regarder les matchs à Bordeaux,
Lyon, Marseille ou Paris.
- Ces appels au boycott
au niveau des villes, il est
un peu hypocrite, surtout
vis-à-vis de la ville de Paris,
parce que le Qatar, outre
le PSG, a quand même beaucoup
investi dans la ville de Paris,
notamment... sur la question
du tourisme de luxe,
pour réar r r r les hôtels,
donc il y a quand même
un lien fort entre le Qatar
et la ville de Paris.
- Dans la capitale française,
inininintérêts qataris ont raché
non seulement le PSG, mais
aussi des hôtels et le magasin
bien connu Le Printemps.
À Paris, les traces de
la présence du Qatar vont
donc perdurer, même une fois
la coupe du monde terminée.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Paris